[Musik]
ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
jedoch unserer kleinen süßen micro fällt
meine lieben freunde ich glaube dass das
hier wirklich der schönste startpunkt
für eine minecraft mit luca folge aller
zeiten bisher war
denn wir sehen hier vorne unsere neu
gebauten schule wir sehen die moderne
strandhaus villa wir sehen allerdings
auch hier die sonne hinter unserem
leuchtturm aufgehen und natürlich auch
selbstverständlich unseres von insel
hier vorne
allerdings haben wir heute wieder extrem
viel surprise surprise auf unserer to do
liste denn zuallererst von mir
geschrieben luca du sagst du hast alles
ordentlich aber dann juckt dich nicht
dass hier unter einem tisch einfach ende
ist und da wollte ich mich heute ein
bisschen darum kümmern denn ich habe ja
noch eine menge drei hellgraue trocken
was glaube ich ich habe auf jeden fall
noch eine menge hellgrauen trocken beton
in das ist auch eine sache die mir
geschrieben wurde
es tut mir leid dass ich dich taube
genannt habe okay okay meine damen und
herren ich hole mir erstmal ganz kurz in
hellgrau und trocken wie thomas der
kisten crêpes er wurde nämlich hier oben
drin gespottet von ruhig beim zuschauen
dann kann ich die jahre auch direkt hier
reinpacken und jetzt nehme den helden
trocken beton und setzten den unter den
tisch so dass hier natürlich auch
selbstverständlich alles seine
richtigkeit hat also hier den hellgrau
und trocken beton hier und hier nahm mir
dass wir auf jeden fall erledigt wir
können hier unten auch auf jeden fall
mal die fackeln abbauen um zu schauen ob
hier unten monster drinnen spawnen oder
ob wir noch was das ganze licht design
angeht das ganze auf ein neues level zu
steppen der mir aktuell nur diese und
diese see laterne hier drin das passt ja
auch eigentlich ganz gut denn oben
leuchten die jetzt nicht weil hier genau
die wand her läuft müsste man gucken
wenn das nicht ausreichen sollte wo wir
noch nicht fällen hinsetzen
allerdings sieht das wirklich sehr geil
aus allgemeinen hier somit den familien
das sind schon coole ideen und auch hier
mit den bechern und sony mit der tafel
schokolade was mir in die kommentare
geschrieben wurde
die sache ist allerdings dass bevor wir
zu dem eigentlichen thema für die
heutige die so kommen dass sie die
wahrscheinlich schon im titel und im
handel
wir fahren nämlich heute wiederum
wir reisen in eine richtung in die wir
bisher noch nicht gereist sind
da bin ich wirklich sehr gespannt was
uns dort erwarten wird die sache ist
allerdings dass mir zuvor etwas bisschen
wieder auf den sack geht unsere ganz
viele geschrieben luca du kannst
wirklich den weg mit einer schaufel auch
zur ducati die dass die uni wurde auf
jeden fall geschrieben dass ich auch
erde mit einer schaufel einfach zu einem
weg machen kann
ich zeige euch das jetzt noch mal ganz
kurz also das hier ist gras ich denke
mit rechts drauf und es ist ein weg den
ich jetzt allerdings die jahre hin sitze
und ich denke mit rechts drauf
es geht nicht so
das funktioniert nicht ich glaube das
liegt irgendwie an der version die hast
du nicht gerade noch da hinten etwas
haben wir in zwei hühnchen dankeschön
auf jeden fall für eure zahlreichen
kommentare also das stand unter den
letzten video mindestens 200 kommentare
von wegen luca du musst das nicht zu
gras machen wenn du da weg in machen
willst ja doch muss ich weil ich
irgendwie ein händler an alte version
spiele oder weil ich irgendwie java
spiele ich habe keine ahnung woran es
genau liegt die sache das allerdings
dass ich mich jetzt erst mal auf die
hundehütte konzentrieren wollte denn da
haben sie aber nun valencia sich ein
bisschen beschwert dass die beide
zusammen irgendwie vor der hundehütte 17
vom daher benötige ich dafür erstmal
granit die ziegel treffe ziegel stufe
die gran die treppe hier den granit und
dann benötige ich dafür auch noch vorne
fichtenholz falltüren und dann hier
vorne noch fichtenholz treppen die sache
sei allerdings dass wir eigentlich auch
noch akazienholz falschen hier ist etwas
so viel betrieb drin
wir benötigen eigentlich auch noch
akazienholz falltüren die sache ist
allerdings dass ich kein akazienholz
mehr habe und ich auch gerade nicht weiß
ob ich das mit eben dem traden kann ob
ich irgendeinen bauer oder keine ahnung
mit wem ich entscheiden muss ob ich das
irgendwie abkaufen kann oder so
allerdings glaube ich dass wir leider
wirklich demnächst dann noch einmal in
das wüsten dorf fahren müssen
allerdings habe ich mir überlegt einfach
diese hundehütte ein bisschen zu
erweitern denn unsere insel ist jetzt
leider gottes auch nicht riesig groß von
da hab ich mir gedacht erst mal bei
dogans kurz hier raus und ein bisschen
mehr platz zum bauen haben also kommen
perfekt wartest du wartest hiermit man
ins lager so genau den bau ich ganz gut
wieder ab die sache ist dass ich leider
kein akazienholz mehr habe und das
benötige nicht eigentlich weil ich hier
noch ein weiter dran setzen wollte zuvor
muss sich allerdings hier erst mal eine
treppe hinsetzen und hier damit wir den
übergang schaffen
und genau das gleiche jetzt auch hier
vorne ich weiß jetzt nicht genau wie ich
das jetzt hier machen soll
ich glaube da muss ich leider mal ganz
kurz diese treppen nehmen und die hier
hinsetzen so dass ich hier vorne mich
dran denken mag so perfekt das hat
geklappt und genau das gleiche jetzt
auch noch mal hier auf der seite da kann
ich jetzt nämlich ganz einfach so kann
ich nämlich nicht machen die muss ich
noch mal neu abbauen weil das nur eine
stufe ist so und jetzt kann ich die hier
vorne so dransetzen haben das jetzt
nämlich perfekt abgeschnitten und können
jetzt auch einfach diese treppen noch
mal ganz kurz abbauen und dann mit
unseren fichtenholz falltüren hier vorne
einmal außen rum gehen nämlich hier eine
hinsetzen und hier vorne auch bamba mund
auf die fichtenholz falschen kommen nun
abwechselnd natürlich die treppen wir
haben ja hier ziegel treppe kann die
treppe deswegen hier wieder eine siegel
treppe und dann auch hier vorne wieder
eine granit treppe und wieder eine
ziegel treppe so dass wir das hier vorne
dann auch dementsprechend super anpassen
können zack und zack und das einzige was
ich jetzt noch machen wollte war hier
vorne einen blumentopf hinsetzen und
dass wir quasi hier so ein bisschen so
eine art futternapf farben und dann
wollte ich halt hier noch eine
akazienholz bald werden packen
ich mache jetzt erstmal eine fichtenholz
falsche hin bzw hab ich ja glaub ich
auch noch schwarz eichenstämme dann
könnte ich ja damit eventuell mal eine
falsche machen die ich so nicht mache
sondern mit exakt so dann könnte ich so
einer dahin packen ist also ein bisschen
schokolade ich wieder aus vielleicht ist
das dann so ein bisschen ein anderes
material ja kann man auch so machen
finden ich habe mit michael ballack
erneut reinpacken auf jeden fall können
wir jetzt mal ins jager einfach hier
links reinschieben damit sie hier vorne
platz nimmt perfekt und balu nehmen wir
jetzt als nächstes jahr soll das mal
ganz kurz hier überlaufen der läuft
perfekt in die falsche richtung
allerdings jetzt hierhin sagt und jetzt
können wir auch wieder so entschieden
wie wir das ja schon damals gemacht
haben als wir die kleine hütte gebaut
haben ich habe mir erst gedacht ich
meine zweite hundehütte allerdings
dachte ich mir dann mensch die beiden
zusammen sondern
ganz neu ist dann können sie sich
vielleicht wissen unterhalten und wie
kaninchen nehmen wir sind ja auch
zusammen im stall
wie gefällt euch denn ihr beiden ich
muss
[Musik]
dieser satz ich werde jetzt trotzdem
einfach mal ein bisschen fitter nicht
wir haben ja noch eine menge verrottetes
fleisch drin soll dann kann ich das mal
ganz gut bei den cia und balu geben
kommen die beiden direkten und zwar
könnt euch bleibt sitzen perfekt wenn da
vorne läuft über und die sonne geht auch
schon wieder runter von daher meine
lieben freunde kommen wir nun zu dem
eigentlichen thema für die heutige wieso
de denn ich habe sehr oft in den
kommentaren gelesen dass ich erst mal
ganz kurz dem blumentopf wir vorne noch
hinsetzen möchte dass dieser mister
perfect und dass sie können wir auch
kurz ein bisschen verwalter machen hab
ich ja leider gerade ein paar gräser
abgebaut also einmal hier kurz drauf und
hier und hier nähe da wollte ich nicht
hier von das geht nicht wegen den fall
könne das egal
das passt auf jeden fall würde ich sagen
ich gehe auf jeden fall ganz kurz
geschlafen wie kommen jetzt allerdings
zum richtigen thema für heutige und zwar
möchte ich endlich einen freund für
unser schwein suchen da steht ja schon
seit wochen auf unserer zielliste bzw
stands glaube ich gar nicht auf dem
schwarzen brett allerdings hat das
schwein ja oft das ganze an gemerkt dass
er ein freund haben will der liebe papa
deswegen möchte ich mich mal wieder auf
reise bewegen werde dafür gar ganz kurz
dass ihre 1 packung zu essen habe ich
genug ich habe ein weißes pferd und ich
habe auch einen kompass von daher
brauchen eigentlich gar nicht viel mehr
außerhalb karotten für das dings aber
die habe ich ja natürlich auch am start
von daher würde ich sagen papa ich suche
jetzt ein freund
du kannst auch mal ein bisschen dankbar
sein dafür dass ich das überhaupt stimmt
nicht die riechen eigentlich mal ganz
gut wir schwingen uns ins brötchen und
fahren in die richtung ich euch gleich
zeigen denn mir fällt gerade noch auf
das ich vorher noch etwas mitnehmen
wollte was wir auch schon lange nicht
mehr gemacht haben und zwar eine an geld
das wäre echt nice wenn ich dann
irgendwann mal was vernünftiges allen
würde ich weiß nicht wo meine angel ist
die haltbarkeit 2 und köder einzig
braucht halt ja eigentlich mehr ich
brauche da 3 oder irgendwie sowas aber
das sollte schon ausreichend also das
passt schon habe ich den bogen dabei
perfekt sollte alles laufen ich nehme
allerdings auch noch mache ein bisschen
holz mit bzw holz kann ich mir von
bäumen abbauen die ich sehen werde aber
reisen nehme ich mir auch mit und ich
nehme auch meinen crafting table mit von
dem ich allerdings glaube ich noch einen
zweiten habe oder habe ich nicht dann
nehme ich auf jeden fall den ich mal
ganz kurz eben mit damit ich einfach
wenn ich unterwegs sein sollte und in
der höhle sehe und da irgendwie kurzen
luzern möchte dass ich mir alles
mögliche mit einer beim start habe
perfekt also meine lieben freund ich
zeige euch jetzt mal ganz kurz welche
richtung gefahren und zwar waren wir
wirklich schon in die richtung dahinten
das medium dann waren wir auch schon in
dieser richtung hinten
der ist ja ganz hinten das wüsten doch
gewesen und wir waren ja auch schon in
der richtung also hin der quasi
entgegengesetzten richtungen die ich
gerade hinfahre
da war ja nämlich unser test land und
die höhe in der wir schon bahn ihr wisst
allerdings dass ich auch schon da vorne
war
da war nämlich unser ozean monument und
da hinten ist ja dass pilz biomechaniker
ich auch noch mal ganz kurz das leben
jetzt ein bisschen am horizont gleich
auf jeden fall noch mal
allerdings war ich noch nie dort hinten
und ich habe mir gedacht na was denn der
war jetzt hier in offen von justin
bieber da hinten am horizont sehen wir
die insel die so ein bisschen diese vor
insel von dem pilz bio darstellt also
nur damit ihr wisst wo ich mich gerade
so ein bisschen aufhalte und hier links
da vorne
kenner wissen bescheid das ist die dass
piraten frack gewesen wo wir uns eine
kleine base gebaut haben weil ich hier
vorne irgendwo das bozner monument war
da wo diese ganzen fische sind und zwei
transporter thunfische wir waren
allerdings auch nicht fordern wir haben
immer nur am horizont hat die
insel hier gesehen die ist allerdings
relativ kleinen mini und pustet sicher
so blöd auf 1 und 2 hier ist nun zweiter
diese kugelfische die muss ich wirklich
immer mitnehmen perfekt ich mal schaden
genommen sagt nach oben und wir fahren
weiter in diese richtung gehen die frage
ich wahrscheinlich lokal wollte
eigentlich keine tiere töten ja
kugelfische mein boot gedreht
kugelfische brauche ich halt für
unterwasser atmungs tränke und die sind
sehr sehr sehr sehr wichtig gerade noch
für den welche sachen die wir demnächst
vielleicht aufbauen möchten
guck mal hier sind echt mega viele
korallenriffe sieht sehr sehr sehr sehr
geil aus was aus minecraft generell
geworden ist und hier vorne geht es
jetzt anscheinend ab also dass sie bei
die kleine insel die wir immer so ein
bisschen von dem ozean monument auf
beobachten konnten
aber hier gibt es anscheinend noch ein
paar mehr insel und das scheint mir eine
wüste zu sein wahnsinn wenn wir
demnächst an sand brauchen müssen nicht
mehr zu den komischen wüsten dorthin
fahren da haben wir einfach hier vorne
wüste das ist auf jeden fall sehr sehr
geil
vielleicht geht er so ein kleiner fluss
durch dann können perfekt geht es
nämlich nicht dann hätten wir noch ein
bisschen durchfahren können allerdings
muss ich jetzt aus dem brötchen
aussteigen und den rest zu fuß erledigen
ich hoffe nur dass wir irgendwann
schweinchen finden werden ich weiß dass
wir auf dem festland zwar auch ein paar
schweine hatten und dann hätte ich da
auch einfach hinfahren können mit dem
ein kart und dann hätte man kann
allerdings dachte ich mir
wir sind lange nicht mehr rumgelaufen
wir waren lange nicht mehr auf
entdeckungstour und daher
mir machen wir das ganze jetzt mal eine
höhle leute treiben exil effekt decker
da habe ich gar keinen bock drauf wir
laufen weiter denn wir haben noch ein
ziel für heute meine lieben freunde und
das ist ein schweinchen ich weiß nicht
[Musik]
sehr sehr sehr sehr wild wir haben eine
menge lapislazuli reisen und das war's
ich bin ganz ehrlich ich möchte nicht
länger jedoch aufhalten denn wir müssen
für das schweinchen den freund suchen
und ich finde wir sind das fand das
jetzt wie ein verspäteter schaden naja
ich finde wir sind ein bisschen schuldig
mit dem freund von daher gehe ich jetzt
mal hier vorne ans festland sehen wir
schon irgendwie schweinchen nähe jedes
keins da oben sind nur bienen und hier
sind keine weiteren tiere davon sind ein
paar schafe da vorne sind auch noch ein
paar schafe hätte ich mir die schere
mitgenommen habe reisen das heißt
theoretisch kann ich denen auch so ein
bisschen wolle abknüpfen und mir ganz
kurz mal eben eine schere machen und
daher springen weil es erstmal zu den
schäfchen übernehmen unser eisen und
können uns eine kurze schere machen und
mal eben hier ein bisschen wolle
mitnehmen hier dann auch noch hier vorne
die wolle ist nämlich echt wichtig denn
sie wurde auch in die kommentare
geschrieben luca es wäre ganz nice wenn
du mal als rache an die kripo einfach
ein kluger kopf hauen würde es genauso
wie halt bei mit der kur und bei dem
scharf wenn ihr zuhause auf der
trauminsel und natürlich den kühler kopf
einfach die luft sprengen ist zwar sehr
fanny die sache jetzt allerdings dass
ich mir gedacht habe mensch ich habe mir
oh mein gott
stellt euch mal vor noch eingefallen
halte auch die sache ist allerdings dass
ich mir gedacht habe
es wäre was ist das perfekt wir haben
direkt schweine gefunden dass es die
sache ist dass ich mir gedacht habe
es mag vielleicht mehr sinn wenn ich
einfach die kripo noch kein pferd niklas
diese schweinchen hier erst mal kurz
alleine und bewegt mich dort vorne rüber
in die richtung aber noch ein paar
andere schweinchen
weil ich mir mal ganz kurz die pferde
anschauen wollt wir haben noch keine
doch ein oder zweimal wir bisher nur in
diesen 80
[Musik]
also ich bin ganz ehrlich mir gefällt es
hier sehr sehr gut wir haben pferde für
wir haben höhlen viele blumen schweine
und schafe und ein dorf auch noch am
horizont also ich bin ganz ehrlich ich
glaube ich werde hier in der nächsten
folge definitiv noch ein bisschen das
dorf nach vorne entdecken
ich werde mir jetzt auch erst mal ganz
kurz ein brötchen reifen weil ich
absolut nicht mehr sprinten kann hier
noch mal ganz kurz das schaf scheren und
dann guck mal hier vorne geht auch noch
weiter mit den ganzen tieren es ist ja
echt brutal die sache ist allerdings ich
will mich nicht ablenken lassen
erst mal ganz kurz das kiefer thema zu
ende zu bringen ich habe mir gedacht
dass ich eventuell einfach den nächsten
krieg den ich sehe der wahl natürlich da
hinten nehmen wo habe ich jetzt auch
kein tnt dabei dass ich die nächsten
krieg mit seinen eigenen waffen in die
luft jagen und einfach tnt mitnehmen
redstone facto werden sie bei mir zu
nahe kommt dann springe ich ihnen
einfach wenn die luft damit er sieht wie
das jetzt so da ist mal ein plan mit
diesem schönen sonnenuntergang wenn die
lieben freunde würde ich die heutige
folge jetzt allerdings auch beenden ich
wollte eigentlich ein freund für das
schweinchen suchen
allerdings hätte ich jetzt gar nicht
gedacht dass wir hier so eine coole welt
werden kommen hier gibt es am fluss lang
eine menge tiere wir haben da hinten die
höhle
wir haben hier den fluss der hier so
lang geht einmal hier drumrum hier außen
langen dann haben wir hier die wüste die
weitergeht vielleicht ist da immer noch
einen tempel oder eine pyramide oder so
und wir haben hier das dorf
auch echt nicht gerade klein aussieht
also das können der nächsten folge noch
erkunden schreibt mir zudem gerne in die
kommentare was ich noch in der nächsten
folge machen soll ich gehe jetzt
schlafen ich weiß nicht warum mir sagt
dass ich nur nachts schlafen kann weil
der mond da hinten schon auf geht doch
vorne vielleicht jetzt jetzt geht's auf
jeden fall meine lieben freunde
es war eine folge der sehr viel quatsch
habe in der ich glaube ich sehr wenig
geschnitten habe allerdings sehen wir
uns genau hier in der nächsten folge in
vier tagen wieder lassen hoch unter
video abonniert main kanal noch keine
linke seite und klickt auf die glocke
wenn ihr das neue video nicht verpassen
wollt wir sehen uns
[Musik]